Biblically,
boop and Gobbledy Goop,
coffee on a Tuesday and blog,
41.
Okay.
Reading over last week,
Sunday Times,
I came across this article by Christie
Wampole,
how to live without irony,
airs out certain grievances and
irritation she has about hipsters.
The archetype she says of ironic living,
the hipster haunts every city,
street and university town manifesting
enough style for times he never lived
himself.
This contemporary urban harlequin
appropriates outmoded fashions,
the mustache,
tidy shorts,
mechanisms,
fixed gear,
bicycles,
portable record players and hobbies,
homebrewing playing trombone.
He harvests awkwardness and
selfconsciousness before he makes any
choice.
He has proceeded through several stages
of self scrutiny and wouldn't it be nice
if columnists proceeded through those
same several stages of self scrutiny
themselves.
She continues to exhibit ironic
tendencies.
For example,
I find it difficult to give sincere
gifts.
Instead,
I often give what in the past would have
been accepted only at a white elephant
gift exchange,
a kitschy painting from a thrift store
or a coffee mug with flashy images of
Texas,
the lone star,
state plastic Mexican wrestler figures.
The simple act of noticing myself
defensive behavior has made me think
deeply about how potentially toxic,
ironic posturing could be.
The simple act of noticing myself
defensive behavior has made me think
deeply about how potentially maybe I'm
guessing that you guys are bad gift
givers to.
Right.
Okay,
so the crux of this article is that
ironic living exemplified by hipsters is
a defense mechanism that allows us to
evade the vulnerable intensity of naked
personal interaction.
She hangs a lot of this on the digital
toys we carry around with us and a deep
desire for sentimentality and nostalgia
and I must say that nostalgia,
sentimentality and defense mechanisms
are all conditions that I suffer from.
They also happen to be numbers 12,
35 and 63 respectively of the human
condition for a full list of the human
conditions.
You can visit yourself and yet even if I
suffer from these symptoms,
I don't know that you could diagnose me
with the supposedly endemic of ironic
living.
Really.
I don't know anyone.
When you get down to it,
who you could diagnose with that.
After I came back from Paris,
the most frequent question I was asked
was not really a question at all,
more of a statement with a question
mark.
At the end of the French,
people don't like Americans,
right?
This I found perplexing because for the
six months that I lived there,
not a single French person treated me
poorly for my Americanness and
affliction I am no doubt soaked.
In fact,
the people I met there were so generous.
The relationships so easily formed and
quickly deep that I was doubly perplexed
by the stereotype to these people I
answered.
Invariably,
every man is his own man.
Every woman,
her own woman kind people like to be
treated kindly and French.
People who walk around with sad faces
like to be asked what's wrong in France
and at home,
I have friends who have typewriters and
fixed gear bicycles who brew their own
beer and cover their walls with stuff
they found on the side of the street.
Some are politically active.
Others not so much.
Some are certain who they are and what
they want to do.
Others not so much.
Sometimes they look at their phones when
I talked to them,
other times they walk around with sad
faces.
I asked them what's wrong and they tell
me.
Sometimes they ask me.
Finally one Paul writes,
what will future generations make of
this ramp and sarcasm and unapologetic
cultivation of silliness.
Will we be satisfied to leave an archive
filled with video clips of people doing
stupid things?
Stupid things,
Huh?
Exhibit a Charlie McDonald's last video.
I'm scared.
Exhibit B,
Nine hundred and 21,835
views.
Exhibit C,
40,000.
Seventy two comments.
I'm proud to be part of an archive of
passionate people saying sincere things
and I'm convinced that what we do is
contagious and if I may be so bold as to
state a common mission,
it's to circulate with force the notion
that every person is at all times going
through something and that it's not
right to judge individuals based on
groups if it is at any time,
right to judge individuals.
Period.
A simple message,
but a strong one and I was sure that
understanding it was part of the
interview process for professors at
Princeton University.
Don't get me started.
I'm really professors
tell me that the system can be that.